on
the walk off set no no no i'm not
putting it on over there
it's a hoodie you can't wear it with a
raw skin
exposed
[Music]
which one was the most expensive
probably the yuckier one
that wasn't that was actually a thousand
that's justified that one
not the other ones guess we bought that
one chris
joe
that's actually joey did buy it as well
i bought the
how do you put on a hoodie like a boomer
i don't know how you've managed to find
a way to do it
do you put it on there it's a [ __ ]
hoodie
do you never wear hoodies
wait actually i've never seen christmas
i've seen about i've never seen you wear
a hoodie
swamp monster
who's coming out have you ever worn a
hoodie before chris oh my god chris in a
hoodie just looks like that [ __ ] like
hello fellow kids
we need to give you a skateboard now oh
my god am i one of the kids now you
should have worn the cap that you wore
previous episode
look good good good good feel
you got the drip now chris
[ __ ] off
that's premium material that chris
that's an embroidery right there
eighty-eight dollars
it's good material right
that's good
that's right
it's just looks so weird it looks like a
dwarf or something right yeah
this is a size too big yeah it's a large
let's not beat around the bushes
[ __ ] a doodle d
but i think you know i'm at least a
medium
in what universe
so what are your goals for 2022 what's
what we're going to expect from trash
here we can see a special the pewdiepie
and mr b stone finally well if the world
[ __ ] opens up yeah i would love to
have pewds on and uh people from outside
japan as much as we want you on for like
a fifth time yeah
when the good when the japan finally
opens up
i don't even know how to get here like i
got on a taxi i was late i got a taxi
ride yeah and i put the address in for
this studio and it just does not compute
on google for whatever reason
so i i put in the dress for somewhere
nearby like it was a domino's pizza
such a [ __ ] going from tokyo station
to a dominoes
film our next schedule special chris
what's up whatever there is a special
what i'm i'm waiting on your special
what are you well it'll be out by the
way like cook some food or something
yeah yeah yeah well that's my name yeah
that's already out by the way oh yeah
yeah
i've been out what
[Music]
this is the man who has traveled all of
japan
[Laughter]
trombone or
jesus the new krakatoa
the trombone of kendo i am affable
though oh my god
what about you chris
are you working on anything else big no
where'd you go out from ken watanabe
right it's nothing is there some uh yeah
so i my friend
who can get me like anyone to interview
he's like who do you want to feel no no
no
anyone i know i know i go you could
probably like get me anyone bring me
anyone
and i just don't have any idea i don't
really i don't really like i don't
there's no one i actually want to
interview you know it's andrew
he's amazing
much worse than the last [ __ ]
interview
expression welcome
thank you
[Laughter]
and the problem is i the comment i get a
lot is like
production quality so good production
quality i don't really production
qualities i don't really care about that
it's important have a standard yeah yeah
yeah
but or not if it's a joey vlogger i
think you've just got the second channel
video i think you've just done it so
much that you i think you just
subconsciously put it together really
well yeah yeah i don't think you're like
this
this mastermind that everyone thinks you
literally just turn up but you make the
most of every situation i think i think
you're pretty good at filming on the
spot maybe yeah just have a knife
whereas whereas i would give up after
two takes and be like [ __ ] it chris is
like we'll just piss everyone off and
make us do like four more takes because
chris is not happy with it
like the stanley key word
all freezing dying hungry
i need this drone shot the colonoscopy
will go on
you're gonna be in my film
what's the film something very bad
chris
i'm predicting that's right christopher
i want to be my movie
so be the racist white man or something
that's what he would do no acting
required
[Laughter]
you guys should do his best to maybe
just basically lean out of the caprio
from django
where's the script
[Laughter]
your character is gluttonous you have to
eat this entire wank sober it's like oh
my god
i don't know honestly i don't know what
to do this year though i would like to
do something outside japan a little bit
yeah
get out there well i haven't listened in
like two years
i haven't left japan in two years plus
now and uh yeah
japan is a country you need to get out
of at least once a year
uh because it's like one big one big
[ __ ] library and you have to sort of
be very careful with your manners and
you've got to be you know switched on
all times thinking about how you're
affecting other people yeah it wears you
down and uh yeah you do need to get out
once a year
pretty tough not not going back or doing
anything i've left the shores of japan
for two years now when was the last time
you like filmed a video in like outside
of japan like in the uk or wherever i
think i've only done it like once wasn't
asking the movie
oh and that yeah that was it yeah that
was it that's the movie and one other
movie right yeah yeah or one other video
another yeah but yeah i just need to get
out for a bit i was yeah i was planning
to go back for christmas like uh you
guys were and
yeah that didn't go well yeah it didn't
go too well and um
yeah
anyway you want to film aside from
krakatoa
i do want to see that
can we climb krakatoa what does that
think i thought i i think to a certain
point
i'll be doing the drone
you can climb i'll be doing the drone
i'll do the drone i'll do the drone
but i do want to do taken for granted
and i i know a place we could bungee
jump in my prefecture
thank god you're there thank god you
want a bungee jump oh my god no i'm
going to film it yeah you're going to do
it with me hold the camera come on
that sounds fun i want you to actually
jump yeah that sounds fun
i think that'd be scarier than doing a
skydive
i i would rather skydive i don't i
wouldn't do it i want a skydiving
[ __ ] wacky weekend dude why are we
not doing it why don't you probably i'm
not [ __ ] doing it yeah i'll do it all
right we'll film that we'll strap some
gopro then we can do it with god
well i'll take both of you yeah [ __ ] it
yeah that's it
i'm all right man
joey doesn't even like
jump oh yeah oh hell yeah then i i'd
skydive as well i i want to scout
when's the traffic skydiving i wouldn't
mind skydiving honestly but i think
bungee jumping i would not want to do
there's something like like there's
something
scary about an awkward height
you know what i mean like where's like
because like for me sky diving is like
you're so high up where height doesn't
matter anymore
i've heard so many funny stories about
bunda jumping in like really sketchy
countries yeah yeah
people do die doing it i read an article
last year did it and the rope just
wasn't [ __ ] tight exactly
let's be honest the one country you
probably want to bungee jump in with
confidence is probably japan yeah yeah
yeah the man the man is like i made this
rope by hand it's all handcrafted or
something fast down from generation yeah
it would be it would be like the most
immaculate bungee jump chord in
existence yeah yeah yeah yeah needs to
study it or something yeah i bet it's
amazing yeah
that's because that's how everything is
in japan yeah nothing can be subpar
to be like the best thing on earth
exactly that's the video chris there you
go what's the health and safety
regulations in japan
uh immaculate because okay okay here's
over the top here's the thing it's like
it's either one or the other because
sometimes it's like [ __ ] immaculate
you are not going to go to this place
unless everyone's signed off on it and
then you have like drifting where you
can turn up without a [ __ ] driver's
license yeah and go on the course i'm
just like so where does the line start i
feel like rules are made when people do
dumb [ __ ] and accidents happen yeah so i
feel like in some sense japan doesn't
have as many rules because they're just
so conscious about yeah stuff like that
yeah like i think like
everyone is just extremely clean here so
i imagine that their health rules
probably aren't as strict on like i
imagine maybe i think maybe they're so
clean yeah i think they're like in japan
because japanese people just like love
to follow the rules and are really good
at following the rules so it's like just
have like a baseline rule set and then
most places will be like you're not
gonna do anything like weird and stupid
to like you know try and test those
limits right because everyone's going to
follow the rules your drifting was fun
though yeah whereas with drifting they
were like do you have a license no all
right you can still do it all right
i'm glad i didn't drift that down i know
i'd have been sick like you were like i
want to see you when i was in the back
of it just for that like few minutes
yeah it's way different when you're
driving it i think yeah like when you're
in the back you get way sicker yeah yeah
it was really fun i really want to do it
again yeah i want to that was fun yeah
big one
i like to see you with like the drift
king drifting you around yeah
hasn't flashed before my eyes before but
they definitely did during that uh
during that year
that drifting episode that was insane
yeah i don't know i don't even know
wanna know how i learned how to do that
[ __ ]
i repeat